uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is this real
3d print yeah that's a real print
i think
[Music]
dude dude that's so cool
good thing you didn't see the gopro
oh my god
you're cooking up a really high-res 3d
print dude
this is the highest rose three three
dude the longest printing time dude the
longest there's like a nine month print
i know i've been sitting here waiting
like yeah nico does these 33-hour prints
man
that's nothing compared to what i got
into
how's it making you feel man dude
honestly i was super nervous kind of
like printing this and setting up the
camera like i was like
i mean about having a kid though oh
that's the easy part if you think it's
cool that there's going to be a baby g
in the world hit subscribe and ring that
little bell dude i want to hear all the
bells around the world ring ding ding
ding ding
[Laughter]
did
each one of us should have one of these
at our desk and instead of slack we just
print each other messages desk updates
just thought of a really dumb way to
waste time and it's called a 3d printing
a stop-motion video
on this plate so you print a frame and
just pop it and each frame takes like 10
minutes and you just like pop it off
print the next one and then you have
like a moving 3d print that's in stop
motion that's a cool idea i think you
can get like that rainbow filament so
the whole thing changes colors yeah
that's that's a good like intro you
could do like a cool channel intro with
that i don't think making a full video
but we keep talking about it becomes a
full video yeah because it's becoming a
full video right now yeah you can do
anything you want
watch this which starts starts a little
something like this
take a drone flying there oh photo scan
of a road damn i just modeled your whole
environment
you put a dog
inside of a fake car put it on a green
screen
also i have two i have two more
questions number one
can my dog luna play the dog the roll
has already gone to ob
the roll's already gone to opie
no it has not i'm just kind of hoping
for like a yellow lab or a golden
retriever but oh you want like a big dog
a helmet a 3d
if it has wings on the side and then
like bones like she's got a big bone
absolutely do this
all i had to do to convince ren and jake
to do a full cg video is to 3d print out
a dog helmet
cool all right so
on the list photo scans of a straight
road and maybe a curved part of a road
and then like
we're not even motion tracking anymore
at this point you know what i mean it's
just like once you have a good car or
two and you've got your uh environment
so you're saying parts of this video
will be 100 cg 100 cg shots in this
video that's what i uh
dude guys this
is really not that hard like remember
the shot and darth santa that i did for
the speeder bike that was just a proof
of concept that was really easy to do
it's a photo scan street that spencer
made that that worked out great i'm on
board with the photo scanning idea of
streets like that i think is a great
idea it seems like easier to do that
than to motion track it into crazy shots
and try and deposit it back in real life
like it's fine to do that for like the
shots where they're racing super hard
and they're crashing and the guy's like
doing a tokyo drift in 180. yeah but
what about for all the other stuff when
like they get in the car when they're
leaning up against the car when you're
doing shots of the car new creative
shots
to get around
i think i think i think the real trick
is ideally we have real car interiors
that we can film in we get to experiment
with blender's car rig because blender
apparently has a very like a very decent
pre-built tool for doing car animations
where you basically just slap your model
on a spline path and does everything
else i'm totally down for this video i
did i'm totally down for going out on
effects and stuff but you just can't
possibly expect all this in like a
timely fashion
we are here to now play some more games
of crave crasher with you it's gonna be
a good time so come hang out with us as
we play some video games
youtube.com eco this video is a
sponsored paid promotion by jack in the
box
[Laughter]
we had one of the most interesting
situations on our hands ever in the
studio recently we did a small promotion
for jack in the box where we did a
facebook live stream facebook live
streaming is huge these days we don't do
it enough and i think we should
i can't i can't eat all this dude it's
actually pretty good the hot sauce would
go really well with all these all right
sam's having the hangry chicken hash let
me let me try this
i was i was baking it's hard to resist
it was really cool because we were using
a system that allowed us to video chat
outwards and broadcast that but then
also have a little switchboard that
allowed people to join in kind of like
like a google hangouts and we could
actually just talk one-on-one while
playing the jackman box video game i've
been a big fan of you guys for a long
time it's really cool to actually be
able to talk to you guys like this
[Music]
[Music]
oh that was sweet that was great
that was sick
for crushing sam's time we're actually
gonna give you one of the grand prizes
here you're gonna get a pair of
headphones so congratulations dude
however with any live stream there's
just a little bit of jank it's it's just
a given a charming kind of janka like i
i really appreciate a little bit of jank
jank is the spice of life the system was
being very taxed you know they're trying
to run this game on it we're trying to
run a whole live stream set up you know
there was a lot of a lot of bills and
whistles going on so the system started
to chug a little bit created some really
interesting situations we wanted to
reboot it because it was starting to
really chug and really struggle and when
we rebooted it one lucky person on that
live stream ended up taking over the
entire live stream for up to like i
think it was like two minutes or
something uh we do currently have
someone
taking over the live stream
he's like hey guys dude this guy's he's
getting all these great reactions
he deserves a price they're just like
hey random guy
he just popped in there he's still there
he called his girlfriend over he goes
hey look
i think at first he didn't know what was
happening because we're just watching it
and he's just like sitting there like
you know you wanted to talk to us and
play the game with us i love it i love
it did you tell him he's the host
now yeah i think he eventually found out
i joined in on that live stream when he
was i was i was so confused yeah and
he's just this guy who is this yeah i
even i was like who was who was this guy
once in a lifetime experience
if you're gonna commit to having a cg
car or driving on down a cg street it's
like you're gonna get the craziest
freaking shots you can probably do so
spencer took a drone and flew it around
and got some great photo scans of the
downtown area we are trying to take
these photo scans and convert them into
something usable something that is quick
to access the 3d model of the street
alone is about 300 megabytes and there's
about a gigabyte's worth of textures and
materials for it as well so as you can
imagine it's very taxing on the system
the goal is to figure out a way to make
this a little less taxing on the system
so we can work on shots in real time and
not have to like create some weird weird
bizarre process with proxy files because
we have all of hunter street all of
porter street all the buildings and cars
in between they're all represented as a
3d model one single 3d model if this
works then we are set
it's the best thing in the entire world
[Music]
yeah i'm getting this driving rig down
and it's pretty sweet i i don't actually
have like the actual full dynamics on
either
the car
this is for the self-driving fast and
furious video
hey
i came up with a fast and furious idea
about a year ago and you guys said it
was stupid and that no one wanted to
watch fast and furious because it was
outdated no i came up with this idea and
it was great from the second i thought
of it i am taking some of the coolest
technology from all ends of the world
and smashing it down into one single
place we've got a photo scanned
environment we've got a 3d model i
pirated off the internet i downloaded a
15 gigabyte 3d model pirated pack like
five years ago you know it's from my
pirating days it's from my old pirating
days as a pirate when i met sam and nico
you don't even want to know they had a
whole drive called the fun box
or something like that when you have an
income of two thousand dollars per year
how the hell else are you supposed to
fight are you supposed to buy software
and have fun and play games i was right
there next to you i pirated the first
mass effect i had to do it it wasn't
it's past the statute of limitations i'm
using a incredible plug-in it's a script
for 3ds max called driver master and
really
oh
party bucket yes the party bucket head
back from our pirating days okay so the
last thing i'm using driver master for
3ds max which allows you to create
splines generate ground planes and
geometry
and really quickly easily animate cars
through environment you want chassis you
know rocking physics it's great this is
on this is how we're gonna shoot this
video photo scan environments with the
drone
get crazy 3d model cars and just do half
the shots 100 cg and i think this this
little demo right here i just made
proves how easy it's going to be
[Music]
you